hey everybody its Charlie this is so
awesome they finally confirmed what's
going on with Tom Hollands new infinity
war suit we've all had our suspicions
way back before spider-man homecoming I
thought that they would just backdoor
iron spider him a costume like he was
this very first Marvel movie so of
course they're gonna baby step it so
they want to go with something that
looks very old-school spider-man but
because Iron Man was designing and it's
like what other surprises does it hold
so we learned about that during
homecoming and I was like okay maybe
this is just the version of the iron
spider suit that we'll have in the MCU
technically very low grade compared to
comic-book iron spider because that was
literally just an Iron Man suit painted
to look like a spider-man suit with
extra arms on the back but we got that
post credit scene with the crazy-looking
armor suit so very clearly that was
meant to be the iron spider suit but
still you know we just didn't have any
confirmations about what it did now they
finally released promo art so let's
break this down like it's a little bit
different from what you would think of a
Civil War era classic iron spider there
been a couple different versions of the
iron spider suit in the comics so try to
explain the difference now we can check
out those trailer scenes chart the
timeline and see where it is they're
either omitting stuff or not including
stuff but it's a very fun spin on the
idea of iron man's Hulk Buster costume
so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's gonna be so much Marvel
stuff dropping there is an Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway going on right now but
because there is so much crazy infinity
warmer I'm always happy to do giveaways
for anything else for that - it just the
Infinity Gauntlet is like the most shiny
thing of all that we've been talking
about for the past 10 years so iron
spider if you're wondering what's going
on with his suit this is actually what
the back of it looks like it looks just
like you would expect a normal suit to
look nothing special it's like they're a
crazy amount of nanites it doesn't look
like Iron Man's bleeding-edge armor
which does seem like it's completely
nanite activated the way that black
panther's suit is made of vibranium
nanites so like he wears that necklace
and it just comes out from that same
thing with Iron Man's costume just
nanites form the costume around him like
this is what Iron Man's wings look like
when they stick out the back because of
the nanites he can just create any type
of armor attachment that he wants to so
like he has this hand
Kanon that everyone's been seeing it's
not that he's still using a version of
his Iron Man armory where there's like a
warehouse somewhere and the part flies
on and attaches to him then a nice just
reformed to make the cannon the
difference in the iron spider costume is
it sort of like that joke the difference
between the war machine costume and Iron
Man's newer versions of the costume
where he jokes to Rhodey and says you
wear my 80s hand-me-downs like he's
always wearing a more primitive version
of whatever Iron Man's wearing at the
time I got a ton of new tech I got a
princess dude I got bomb disposal
catcher's explosions midair so last time
you got a good night's sleep
Einstein slept three hours a year same
thing with spider-man's Avengers suit
it's just a more armored version of the
homecoming suit same type of tech like
he still has suit lady in there he still
has the heads-up display the different
webbing but it's vacuum sealed so that
he can survive in outer space so like
you see him hanging on to that assist
ship way up high in Earth's orbit like
you can clearly see that the ship is
going into outer space and he's gonna
die if he doesn't get some sort of
spacesuit on him this is where we get to
the Veronica of it all so what is
Veronica is really like a mobile armory
where things just shoot out based on
iron man's needs hey I need the
Hulkbuster send Veronica in so you have
all these different parts that just
attach to Iron Man's normal armor I'm
calling in Veronica
all right everybody stand so that's kind
of what's going on with the iron spider
costume just like a couple different
parts that attached to him the iron
spider legs that everyone's freaking out
about are just another bronica style
attachment so think of spider-man's iron
spider costume during the movie is being
like Iron Man's Hulk Buster like he
still has his normal costume that he
flies around in but sometimes when he
needs the extra juice in a fight he
calls in the hook Buster and it just
forms around him so spider-man will
still wear that classic homecoming suit
and I think he'll go back to that per
spider-man too because he really does
want to be that friendly neighborhood
spider-man even after this big Avengers
retreat that's going to be happening in
the next two movies there'll be so much
grief and loss that they'll be trying to
deal with in the wake of it that's all
just go back to their normal lives so
spider-man has to go back to high school
after this is all over so back to
friendly neighborhood spider-man back to
the familiar back to Aunt May and that
means back to this version of the suit
but I'm really just talking about looks
that doesn't mean that they won't change
the homecoming suit so let me know in
the comments what do you think about the
iron spider suit and what do you think
is gonna make him go back to the
homecoming cloth suit like do you think
that this suit is gonna get destroyed
because usually what happens with Iron
Man suits the reason why he changes is
just because he picks up in the new
movie he's been tinkering since the
events of the previous movie so imagine
what you would do if you had unlimited
money in the eliminate ability to tweak
with different versions of the suit like
he went full George Lucas on all of his
Iron Man armors which is how you got all
the different versions that's one of the
reasons why they blew them up at the end
of the movie when it was cool but - he
was crazy when he made all those and now
he has the nanite bleeding-edge armor
and he can become any armor that he
needs it to so he doesn't need a hundred
different suits of armor he just needs
this one that can become a hundred
different versions and that's kind of
the direction we're going with Spider
Man like you'll have the classic looking
Spider Man suit but then you'll have
Veronica moments when he needs some
extra juice when he goes into outer
space or there's some crazy tasks to
perform but I think what will happen is
is because of the influence of Black
Panther and Sheree those moments in you
know Avengers 5 like whatever comes
during phase 4 will be inspired by a lot
of black panther technology integration
man Tom's my friend I was contemplating
helping him in the future with his suit
and stuff and just we were just going
back and forth just to be clear though
Black Panther tech in Iron Man tech not
that different they function a lot of
the same way is just that ones based on
vibranium ones based on traditional
science the advantage being that the
Black Panther Tech is much more
integrated with natural biological
systems so it appears to be much more
natural even though on a very basic
level it does all the same stuff as Iron
Man's tech so imagine spider-man in the
future doesn't need to wear a bunch of
different attachments like he still has
a suit that looks like the classic
spider-man suit but when he wants it or
he needs it he can just form his
web-shooters without having to
physically put them on I think they'll
always be a version of the web shooters
I just don't think that he's got to
physically put them on anymore it is a
good example of him just thinking oh I
need my web-shooters and they'll form
around him out of little vibranium
attachments but don't go too crazy with
suit theories just remember
that usually the technology is made to
serve the story so like whatever
spider-man's Ark is during that next
spider-man movie whatever new things
that his suit does will be made to serve
that but the really funny thing because
we have Aaron Davis you know we're kind
of hinting at Miles Morales and
spider-man universe and we have donald
glover character who is the Prowler
they're been at least three other
characters that have warned the armor
during Civil War era the original Civil
War there were the Scarlet spiders which
were a team of clones it looked exactly
like spider-man's version of the costume
more recently Mary Jane Watson wore
version of the costume implying that it
was the version that Peter wore during
civil war then just this January Donald
Glover's character from Home Coming wore
version of the suit but it was after
Secret Wars so Miles Morales woke up in
a different reality his uncle bought a
version of the armor on the black market
obviously it looks a little bit
different than reformed a version of the
sinister six so I'm not expecting them
to do that in the movie universe anytime
soon maybe the animated movies because
we have that spider burst movie that's
coming up it's implied that they'll get
into some multiverse ideas with a bunch
of different versions of spider-man so
maybe that's where we'll see some of
this stuff wait so how many of you say
there is some special spider-man stuff
happening this weekend but it's Tom
Holland into Chawla presenting at the
Oscars hey guys just wanted to let you
know that tomorrow I will be taking over
instagrams
Instagram
I'm not sounds a bit crazy but the
Instagram handle I will be taking it
over and taking you through the Oscars I
just did my razzle now there's a much
more infinity war coming up believe all
your video requests in the comments
below
congratulations to Pablo Alonso please
private message me so I can get your
contact details click here to learn
about the 10 phase for movies they just
announced and click here to learn all
about the flashpoint movie details they
just released thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]